you don't need everybody to do strategic
BD you just need one person in the small
business to do it twice a year you get a
drop of a new client more if you're
effective at what you do now you compare
that to what we have now in an active
Market anybody can do tactical Business
Development it's easy because there's a
shortage of people so if you ring in and
say I got a great candidate go make a
placement but if the market tightens
then they don't need to do that so that
business development don't work anymore
strategic Business Development works all
the time because what you're doing is
building a relationship you're building
a relationship which we both recognize
is actually a Business Partnership
doesn't work with everybody because some
people don't want that some clients just
want the best deal they can get and
that's fine I want clients that are
going to Value me and have a steady
stream of work coming in that I can rely
upon and I want more and more and more
of them it's a completely different way
of building a business to begin with
unique tactical then you need tactical
and strategic if you do it properly you
just have strategic in the end